six one seven eight three zero 4750 is
the number
let's see who's joining us from oh I
don't know maybe the seven eight six
area code who's been holding on for a
while who's calling from seven eight six
Hey good Hey so the question that I want
to ask you is why are people I guess
Republicans are so afraid of democratic
socialism and I want to give you some
context behind this because they come
from Cuba which is very communist and I
know what it's like to be without rights
and without having an ability to you
know share what I'm thinking right so
you want to get yourself on that what
the question is why Republican so
affordably yeah you know there's a
couple different answers to that there
are some who have just been so
indoctrinated by the caricature of
democratic socialism that they just have
this emotionally visceral response and
that is kind of hard to defuse when
you're talking to those individuals the
others have basically been indoctrinated
into standard neoliberal capitalism as
the system and they may have some
accurate ideas about what democratic
socialism is and some inaccurate ideas
you know the truth is that socialism is
much more complex than most people even
really can appreciate and and understand
so you've got a range of social
democracy which is not really socialism
as I've pointed out you're talking about
a more socially conscious and regulated
mixed economy that includes capitalism
and private private ownership all the
way strangling totalitarian Stalinist
communism with one-party state control
of everything and a de facto
authoritarian police state and in
between that stuff there's a really big
range I mean I I actually think it's
less interesting to think about why the
right is so afraid of democratic
socialism because they often don't even
really know what we're talking about I
think it's more interesting to have
people on the Left as I've been trying
to do
discuss the merits and demerits of
socialism versus utopian socialism
versus libertarian socialism versus
social democracy versus the system we
have I think you're gonna get much
further because you're correct in
pointing out that whether you're for or
against socialism you should really
understand what it is if you're gonna
make an argument for or against it and
by and large the right has no clue what
it's talking about on the issue if I
should add something I think that people
should listen more to the ideas of
Bernie and Aleksandra culture because
what they're saying are essentially you
know what Europe is essentially doing
that's Rand and their good ideas at the
NRA
and you should also keep capitalism as a
form of government but you know also at
that end because it is it is helpful for
the community I guess listen part of my
view is that I rarely find the solutions
in extremes and that way I end up and
for many other reasons which I don't
have time for now but maybe you've seen
my clips on it unregulated
vulture capitalism is an extreme and for
me it's not a solution to how society
should be organized state-run single
party totalitarian authoritarian
communism to me is an extreme and it's
not how we should organize society in
the middle there is a gray area where I
am right now and my my feelings have
evolved over my life I am at a mixed
economy that retains private business a
progressive tax system within a broader
capitalist sort of atmosphere or
infrastructure that is heavily regulated
with significant funding put towards
social welfare programs and ensuring
that the basic needs of everybody are
are met with the understanding that you
can't just say the system we have isn't
working well so we'll make a small tweak
to it you you really need to make
significant changes to have true social
democracy that's where I am because I
don't believe in
extremes as the solutions on this on
this particular issue and if people want
to disagree with me go ahead no that's
that's perfectly fine and I definitely
agree there honestly in government there
should be gray area it shouldn't be
black or white you know it just doesn't
work that way in my opinion all right
very good appreciate the call thank you
so much great great to hear from you we
are out of time for calls to everybody
we didn't get to and there are lots of
people holding up close to 15 at this
point I apologize but what I can promise
you is that we will take calls again and
I look forward to hearing from you then